bonjour à tous alors
jouer du violon comme sa marque et sur
la fiche je vais pas j'ai pas je vais
pas jouer tout de suite mais je le pose
est ce que c'est un bel objet je les
amenais dans le train ça m'a coûté un
petit supplément
voilà bah écoutez je suis ravi de vous
rencontrer alors c'est un petit peu
particulier pour moi ce que d'habitude
quand je viens dans un amphi comme ça
c'est pour donner des cours d'économie
et et là je vais pas donner de cours
d'économie
je vais pas parler d'économie parce que
vous avez vous avez tout ce qu'il faut
je pense déjà
on peut m'appeler aussie pour jouer du
violon donc c'est soit l'un soit l'autre
mais là aujourd'hui on m'a appelé pour
parler des deux en fait alors la
première fois que j'ai été contacté par
des étudiants de ge est membre
management
il m'en donner le thème de la conférence
et là je me suis demandé s'il avait bien
compris qui j'étais
ce qu'ils m'ont parlé de briser les
codes et là j'ai fait le point sur ma
vie quand vous faites une conférence et
d'aix est l'occasion de faire le point
sur votre vie donc c'est un bon conseil
que je vous donne fait une conférence
tedx une fois dans votre vie et vous
aller vous allez faire le point et du
cou brisé les codes je ne savais pas
exactement ce que ça voulait dire je me
suis posé la question j'ai regardé un
petit peu mon existence je vote à droite
au centre plutôt centre gauche centre
droite
je m'habille entre le gris et le bleu
foncé
voilà je fais la même profession et par
an j'habite à nantes dans ma ville
natale
rien de très rien de très funky voyez
rien de très particulier quoi donc en
fait j'ai refait le point une deuxième
fois et j'ai compris qu'il voulait me
faire venir parce que je fais deux
métiers un petit peu différent et donc
je voulais parler un petit peu de la
façon dont on peut mêler ses deux
métiers alors quand je suis devenu
enseignant j'ai pris un soin tout
particulier à pas donner de leçon de vie
à mes étudiants vous n'êtes pas mes
étudiants vous n'êtes pas étudiant
d'ailleurs pour certains
donc en fait je vais juste vous livrer
la façon dont moi j'ai traversé ces
dernières années et comment j'ai un peu
mêlé un dilemme qui était assez fort et
ce dilemme était le suivant c'était
comment mais les deux choses qui me
tenait beaucoup à coeur qu'ils étaient
l'économie et de façon générale les
sciences sociales et la musique alors je
vais faire un petit un petit retour sur
ma vie je vous rassure ça peut être très
long si votre voisin s'endort ne le ne
réveillez pas ça va ça va être très
court toute façon à 18 minutes en tout
maximum et en fait c'est le violent ça a
commencé très tôt et j'ai eu l'occasion
de faire ce qu'on appelle un cursus de
musique études
donc quand on fait musique-études c'est
comme quand on fait souvent études vous
faites moitié écoles moitié musique donc
j'ai commencé ça à 7 ans et j'ai fait
tout mon cursus là dedans et comme ça
marchait plutôt bien j'ai eu la chance
de rentrer à une école qui s'appelle à
l'école normale supérieure et a une
faculté qui s'appelle assas en magistère
droit des affaires et là je vais
continuer à faire de la musique
j'ai continué régulièrement à faire de
la musique est là la question s'est
posée au gouvernement de faire un petit
peu un choix entre les deux c'était
c'était devenu rang lacombe poux
relativement complexe parce que le temps
le temps manquait un petit peu le temps
manquait pour la musique notamment
il ya un petit souci c'est que quand
vous faites le ms et que vous annoncez à
vos parents que vous voulez devenir
musicien de jazz on va mère est tombée
de sa chaise
mon père a failli mais il était bien
assis mais c'est compliqué en fait c'est
compliqué de parfois de de lutte et un
petit peu contre les codes sociaux et
notamment contre les milieux familiaux
ou les proches qui vous disent que vous
êtes censés aller dans tel direction ou
tel autre et puis parfois vous avez
juste pas envie de faire le choix il ya
peut-être parmi vous des gens qui
démarrent leur vie active et qui se pose
la question d'un métier de raison on va
dire aux métiers traditionnels et qu'on
à côté de ça une passion artistique ou
sportive convient de faire de
l'humanitaire enfin bref qui se
demandent s'il faut aller vers un métier
qui sera difficile à mener avec lequel
il sera difficile de gagner sa vie ou
alors d'aller vers un milieu plus
traditionnels une entreprise une grosse
organisation qui quels débouchés logique
de leur école par exemple
alors moi j'ai pas briser les codes
volontairement je les ai brisé
on va dire petit à petit par la force
des choses et quand j'ai commencé à
travailler en fait j'ai continué à jouer
j'ai continué à donner quelques concerts
et puis il se trouve qu'au bout d'un
moment j'ai constaté que mes petits
camarades musiciens de jazz certains
prenait des cachets qui était pas mal et
je me suis dit je vais arrêter de jouer
gratuitement et je vais demander de
l'argent
sa voix de la musique pourquoi pas et
donc de fil en aiguille en fête
je me suis retrouvé à faire de la
musique très régulièrement et donc au
bout d'un moment je me suis dit que
j'allais à ménager mes deux vies mais de
vie active pour pouvoir garder une
partie de mon temps pour la musique et
une partie de mon temps pour
l'université la classe préparatoire
alors je tiens à préciser quelque chose
j'ai l'énorme opportunité de travailler
dans un secteur public et de pouvoir
prendre parfois des 10 po parfois du
temps de travailler à distance qui est
pas possible dans tous les jobs passe
qui est pas possible dans tous les
milieux professionnels
j'ai aussi des employeurs qui sont très
compréhensifs donc progressivement j'ai
travaillé dans les deux domaines et
progressivement j'ai essayé de me
construire aussi une petite organisation
personnelle qui me permettaient les deux
alors cette organisation personnelle
elle est très simple c'est tenir un
agenda hyper serré et à voir quand j'ai
une heure ou deux heures pour faire de
la musique devant moi un maximum
d'intensité
un travail le plus efficace possible et
quand je suis dans mon boulot dans mon
job quand je manage ou quand je donne
cours à des étudiants quand je lis avoir
un maximum d'efficacité pour une raison
très simple c'est que quand vous
travaillez avec des musiciens ils se
fichent du fait que vous soyez prof à la
fac et quand vous êtes à la fois que
vous étudiants se fiche que vous fassiez
de la musique il faut être bon dans les
deux domaines donc
donc ça c'est fait ça s'est fait comme
ça j'ai eu aussi l'occasion de tester
beaucoup ce qu'est le travail à distance
parce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez des
moyens exceptionnels de bosser si votre
employeur vous le permet chez vous ou
éventuellement d'accomplir des missions
ou de faire des projets qui dans lequel
vous utilisent énormément de ji
collaboratif donc ça c'est quand même
une énorme chance il ya une troisième
chose que j'ai décidée c'est de trouver
un statut ou en tout cas trouver une
organisation professionnelle qui
permettait de facturer en fait et
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas une façon de
travailler vous en avez 50 d'accord
par exemple moi je me suis installé
comme auto entrepreneur est donc en tant
que violoniste bosse en freelance j'ai
pas la capacité de suivre un groupe en
tournée puisque par définition je peux
pas quitter le monde emplois pendant
plusieurs semaines de rang donc je
facture la prestation les gens
m'appellent et quand je suis disponible
givet et quand je suis disponible et
quand je suis pas disponible iv pas donc
je travaille avec des gens qui peuvent
se permettre de rajouter un musicien de
rajouter un prestataire et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il ya énormément de
personnes peut être parmi vous qui
cherche à développer une passion qui
peuvent pas le faire à plein temps mais
qui peuvent éventuellement se trouvaient
quelques moments dans la semaine où
quelques moments dans l'année pour aller
travailler dans un domaine qui est
totalement différent
alors ça c'est un nécessité de de briser
un certain nombre de barrières
d'abord des barrières personnel c'est à
dire que on se on se voit pas toujours
accomplir de métier ou en tout cas on on
pense pas forcément accomplir plusieurs
choses à la fois
alors moi ça a été quelque chose d'assez
assez personnelle assez intime mais
c'est un gros souci de santé qui m'a
fait dériver un petit peu de mon
objectif principal
quand j'étais en classe préparatoire et
quand je suis rentré à normale sup
j'étais un étudiant qui était plutôt
performant et je voulais aller au
sommaire alors moi c'était
l'administration publique dont je
voulais le premier ministre peut se
marrer publique ce genre de choses
après avec le recul je me suis dit que
ce job était pas si génial que ça donc
j'ai pas regretter mais bon en tout cas
ce souci de santé m'a fait prendre un
petit peu de distance avec ce qu'on
considère comme une réussite personnelle
quoi une vie réussie en fait par exemple
arriver au top management d'une grande
entreprise ou arriver au top de la
fonction publique dans un ministère ou
attaché parlementaire où je sais pas je
sais pas quoi donc en fait j'ai pris un
peu de distance avec ça si vous
choisissez de poursuite de voix à la
fois par définition vous pouvez pas les
pousser jusqu'au bout
donc c'est difficile de rivaliser avec
les gens qui se lèvent le matin en
faisant que de la musique toute la
journée et c'est difficile de rivaliser
avec des gens qui font que de la
recherche ou que l'enseignement toute la
journée
donc ça veut dire que vous faîtes
quelque part des choix quelque part des
compromis message l'a accepté à titre
personnel rapidement par contre dans
l'entourage ça a été un peu plus dur
les amis parfois vous
vous questionne mes collègues quand
j'étais à le nsc quand je leur ai dit
que je choisissais plutôt de travailler
à temps partiel dans une université en
provence bien qu'elle soit elle soit
exceptionnel et que le travail que je
sois soit soit soit exceptionnel lui
aussi parce que je vois d'état
d'étudiants et c'est un métier génial
c'est un métier passion c'est pas c'est
pas un métier
deux raisons avancées un métier de
passion avec l'enseignement de
l'économie mais mes amis m'ont posé la
question et on parle certains n'ont pas
vraiment compris mon choix en fait il ya
aussi une autre difficulté c'est le
milieu familial peut-être c'est vrai que
pour certains d'entre vous comme on l'a
dit c'est c'est une pression en fait il
ya aussi la contrainte financière c'est
à dire qu'un certain nombre de métiers
ou un certain nombre de patients vous
permettent pas de gagner votre vie
normalement en fait quand j'interroge
mes étudiants en première année par
exemple beaucoup me disent qu'ils
veulent travailler dans l'humanitaire
parce que ce qui est beau ce qu est ce
qui est symbolique c'est bon signe mais
ils savent qu'ils trouveront pas tous un
job bien rémunérés dans une organisation
humanitaire
ils arriveront pas tous à vivre de leur
passion donc ça c'est une contrainte
aussi mais avec deux sources de revenus
vous pouvez vous pouvez vivre et une
fois qu'on a dépassé un petit peu ses
codes et ses difficultés il ya je dirais
une ou deux exigences importantes et
aussi des tas davantage l'exigence
importante c'est comme je disais tout à
l'heure d'avoir un maximum d'efficacité
donc un petit peu comme alban à qu'il
discutait trailer qui est l'intervenant
qui va suivre
quand vous faites je pense de la musique
ou du sport de haut niveau
pour moi c'est la musique jouée est
sportif de haut niveau quand j'étais
jeune
comme je l'expliquais mais j'ai vite
abandonné je voulais de basketteur mais
on m'a expliqué que c'était pas possible
c'est pas la peine de rire mais bon j'ai
vite opté pour la musique
du coup c'était à priori c'était un peu
plus mon truc mais ça demande un travail
très intense et donc en fait j'ai très
rapidement appris à bosser le plus vite
possible c'est-à-dire à faire deux
journées en une
donc à pouvoir entre 7h et 17 ou 18
heures faire une journée d'université
aller en classe prépa est joué
faire un concert le soir et répété
éventuellement le matin avant de partir
au boulot enfin voilà essayer de d'avoir
des journées qu'ils soient bien chargé
qui soit bien complète et quand je
travaille une heure généralement je la
remplis un maximum comme la plupart
d'entre vous j'imagine mais bon voilà on
cherche tous à améliorer l'efficacité
qu'on a au travail et je pense que le
violon et l'économie sont deux bons
moyens d'améliorer votre efficacité au
travail
il ya une autre exigence c'est que c'est
que les gens vous font pas spécialement
de cadeaux et est donc vous devez être
bon dans deux domaines qui sont
relativement étanche de domaine
relativement c'est pareil donc il faut
accepter d'avoir quelque part de vie et
deux exigences professionnelles
le bon côté c'est que vous avez deux
vies et deux exigences professionnelles
donc en fait vous avez deux personnages
voient donc il ya des gens avec qui je
travaille à l'université qui savent pas
du tout que je fais de la musique ils
pensent que je vois un petit peu le
dimanche après midi dans un petit groupe
de campagne très bien les amis musiciens
la plupart ceux qui ne sont pas intime
en tout cas savent pas du tout du tout
je suis économiste ce qui est plutôt bon
signe ça veut dire que je suis pas
encore trop à la ramasse comme on dit
quand je joue quand ils me feront la
remarque j'arrêterai la musique je pense
donc ça le fait d'avoir de vie c'est
quand même quelque chose d'assez
passionnant ça fait qu a pas de routine
en tout cas il y en a beaucoup moins et
ça fait que vous pouvez dans une journée
dans une semaine ou dans une même année
vivre des choses totalement différentes
ça s'est relativement inoubliable il ya
il ya un autre
un autre gros avantage aussi c'est que
c'est que vous êtes amené à partager un
petit peu cette expérience et vous
pouvez créer un petit peu des synergies
et du coup il ya un point commun quand
même quand vous vous adressez à un amphi
ou quand vous adresser à un public
je sais pas si j'ai réussi aujourd'hui
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est très
particulier je parle un peu de ma vie
perso et c'est la première fois que
c'est un petit peu particulier tout cas
devant un public
ces textes mais quel est le point commun
entre un public d'étudiants et des gens
qui viennent vous écouter en concert
quel point commun y en a un
vous êtes sympas
mais lui il et du staff ouais il écoute
des fois oui ces écoutes il écoute mais
s'ils écoutent pas pardon la passion
ouais la passion mais peut-être plus
pour public que pour les étudiants ça
dépend moi j'ai beaucoup d'envié de
première année
en général il ya la passion mais pas
toujours enfin toujours mais dans le
meilleur des cas ya la passion c'est
vrai un autre point commun un peu plus
négatifs
si si ça leur a pas plu la première fois
vous les reverrai jamais c'est ça le
point commun en fait donc en fait quand
je donne un cours j'ai une idée très
très simple il faut que les étudiants
viennent la semaine suivante c'est tout
voilà donc en fait ça ça vient un petit
peu de la musique aussi c'est à dire que
il ya tellement aujourd'hui de cours
extraordinaire sur internet vous avez
tellement de cours en ligne a juste des
ressources qui sont exceptionnelles vous
pouvez sus des cours d'économie qui sont
donnés par des prof de harvard
je serai pas mieux c'est sûr et donc
l'avantagé c'est que vous avez une
espèce de synergie est un métier et de
l'autre et je pense que les autres
intervenants figureront sais d
expérience qui sont qui sont proches
arriveront peut-être un petit pot même
conclusion vous avez forcément un métier
forcément nourrit l'autre et je pense
que la fête de faire un petit peu de
scènes ça nourrit sa rubrique forcément
la façon on fait des cours d'amphi y est
et le fait de travailler aussi comme
manager dans une école puisque quand on
est dans une école ou dans un lieu on
est obligé de faire du management et de
faire un peu de management
quand on bosse avec des jazzman c'est
plutôt utile voilà il ya un dernier
avantage et je vais finir par ça c'est
qu'on a l'occasion de partager son
expérience avec des des étudiants on a
l'occasion de venir à grenoble et donc
je vais finir cette petite intervention
en remerciant particulièrement les
membres du staff
choukroun qui est là bas
c'est son vrai nom c'est son nom de
famille c'est ça je me suis dit je me
suis posé la question et je veux
remercier particulièrement et mafany
coke était une de mes étudiantes en
classe préparatoire qui voulait
tellement cette école et qu'il l'a eu et
c'est pour ça que je fais ce métier
c'est pour que les étudiants atteignent
leurs rêves et leurs objectifs merci
emma elle est rouge du coup elle est un
petit peu un petit peu timide elle donne
un sens à notre existence
merci beaucoup alors on m'a demandé de
jouer un petit peu et je crois que ça va
se faire un peu plus tard donc c'est
possible que je joue un petit peu plus
tard voilà un petit peu d'habitude j'ai
un groupe avec moi là je suis tout seul
mais c'est pas grave je vais jeunes
dévoyés en tout cas je remercie pour
votre attention
merci beaucoup